Speaker 1: Hey, this is something very, very
interesting. Rioting as a family affair, a mother
and son rioted together on January 6th. Isn't that
loving? Is that an act of love? Would we call it
that? They've now both been arrested? OK, New York
mother and son arrested in theft of Pelosi's staff
laptop during the Capitol riot NBC News reporting
that the FBI have arrested Marianne Mooney Rondon,
55, and her son Rafael Rondon, 23, of Watertown,
New York, in connection with a stolen laptop,
according to court documents. This is actually
out of Alaska, which is where they ended up
finding the computer. Apparently, a New York
mother and son have been charged with theft in
aiding the disappearance of a laptop belonging to
the staff of Nancy Pelosi during the Trump riots,
after the FBI initially raided a home 4500 miles
away from D.C. in Alaska looking for the computer.
The FBI have arrested, as I mentioned, Marianne
Mooney, Rondon and her son Rafael Rondon
in connection with that laptop used only for
presentations, according to court documents. Both
also face other charges related to the riot at
the Capitol. Rafael Rondon also faces possession
of classic and unregistered sawed off shotgun.
Both were in federal court Friday in Syracuse,
New York, released pending further proceedings.
Now there is even a question you know, the
Trumpists have been saying these folks are being
treated so unfairly held in a sawed off shotgun.
Rioting at D.C. and they're just released pending
further proceedings. If anything, it seems these
folks may be treated very lightly by the criminal
justice system so far. Break into the Capitol,
steal Pelosi's laptop, sawed off shotgun charge
and just walk free pending further proceedings.
Now there's significant reform to be done here.
But the point is the argument that they're all
being treated disproportionately unfairly
for political reasons clearly doesn't apply
to everybody. Capitol riot was well documented by
those who took part. A tip to the FBI led them to
the mother and son, according to a statement
of facts documented by an FBI special agent
Mooney Rondon. That's the mom allegedly admitted
to being in both the Capitol the day of the riots,
as well as Nancy Pelosi's conference room. She
allegedly provided gloves or a scarf to a man.
To steal the laptop without leaving fingerprints.
He asked, he said, give me I don't know if it was
gloves or a scarf I was wearing. And like I said,
he scared me. The document quotes her as saying
There's also another interesting thing here that
I think is relevant o the level of premeditation,
OK? They want to push the idea that everything was
spur of the moment. Look at this. Rafael Rondon,
that's the son, told police officers that he and
mother took the metro on January six quote because
I'm not taking my car into the city, which the
capital building I'm about to break into really
undercuts the idea that this was some kind of spur
of the moment thing. They seem to be saying we at
least suspected that things were going to get sort
of crazy. And so we deliberately didn't bring the
car. We took public transit instead, at least some
degree there of foreknowledge or premeditation.
So we will we will follow this case as we're
following other cases. But mother and son,
mother and son, can you imagine and the stories
about these individuals, I mean those and I'll
be transparent. You read about many of these
stories. They're just sad. It's sad people.
But that doesn't mean that they shouldn't
be held accountable. And in fact,
we're going to talk about that in the next
segment, which is there has not been nearly
enough accountability for the Trump riders.
We'll get to that after this short break.